turn to developing news at this hour
gunshots on the las vegas strip
overnight
that's right alex metro police say the
victim in this shooting is in the
hospital the shooter though still on the
loose bianca holmen live
near the flamingo with the latest
details bianca
hey good morning john good morning alex
so this is a developing story right now
metro police still in front of the
flamingo hotel investigating this
situation
but they want to make it clear this is
an isolated incident and there is no
danger to
the public or of course people out here
on the las vegas boulevard right now
investigators say the shooting happened
around 2 20 this morning
during a fight outside the flamingo one
person was shot
the victim was then rushed to umc trauma
but is expected to survive
as far as the gunman we don't have a lot
of information we know he took off on
foot and is still outstanding right now
detectives are on scene looking at
surveillance video on the flaming uh
from the flamingo uh hotel and of course
other nearby resorts
lots of cameras out here for them to
look at they have not yet released a
description
or said where they think the person ran
to and so again to be clear police uh
because this is still an active scene
they do want us to be sure that we let
you know that there is no danger to the
public
at large and also there is a portion in
front of the flamingo right there on the
sidewalk that's closed off
of course they're combing through that
area for evidence reporting live bianca
holman
8 news now we're going to send it over
to name with the traffic update
speaking of that we do have a camera
also near there from the regional
transportation commission bianca is on
the southwest corner of flamingo and the
boulevard
now the regional transportation camera
is up a little bit higher
so there are what's left of the police
obviously a much bigger scene there
about 2 30 this morning when the
shooting took place
these folks are southbound on las vegas
boulevard that's flamingo east and west
across your screen
so the right lane is still taken away
you have to be very careful through
there but obviously not a lot of traffic
at this hour